Nhưng hãy nhỏ tìm tảy hài học sinh, sế sông lập mộ ở vía ăn.
Sơ việc sẽ ra vọc khoảng 18,5 mồ táng 18.
Thế giếm đó, nơi rất bản lửa, sả sả lửa, sả bửa sông lập mộ,
phát hiện của nảo của 2 học sinh để trên bửa sông khi ngờ các chào biệt đối mạnh.
Nơi ra những trong trình báo với trị quyền địa phương,
những được tin báo, lựng lượng chức măng cùng nửa ra khẩn trưng đi tìm kếm hài chờ bài sức đêm.
Được biết, 2 bộ của nảo trên mở là của Cháo CABT,
tạm tuổi con nông cà về sê và cháo lửa a tê tạm tuổi con nông lửa veka.
Lọc sinh lấp bà đều chủ tệ sả sả lửa, bài chả mi thông tin đêm,
cho các bê tê được tin tảy trên sông đập mộ,
là chạy qua liệu phát bản món, thì chân tạy sảm,
quyền tương dân, kích nơi sảy ra sự việc khoảng hơn 5 km để phía hậu buồn.
Chức đó, cháo lửa a tê đã được tin tảy lúc mề bộ sơ,
chưa ngày mong hài tả mề bộ, đại sinh các uống, chính quyền, các măng ngang đần tìy.
Tức dân sẽ xà lửa vấn đồng đồng vý dân cho bạn lăng, đại đệ chia bồn,
đậm viên hỗ trợ cho hài ra điểm cho bế.